[Applause]
fire and fury from European Farmers no
sign yet of an end to their anger
towards their respective governments and
the European Union across the continent
from Slovakia to Spain there is deep
unhappiness with Rising costs plans to
implement green policies and fears that
the market will be flooded with cheap
imports from Ukraine after the EU waved
quotas and duties on its products after
Russia's
Invasion we're demonstrating against
Europe against the common agricultural
policy the bureaucracy and the countries
that are placing products inside the
country without Health controls we just
can't compete with
them Farmers across Europe have been
shouldering the burden of rising costs
of energy fertilizer and transport added
to that governments have been trying to
reduce prices for consumers as inflation
continues to affect European
economies in Strasburg while Farmers
protested outside the European
Parliament the climate commissioner
stated his case for the block to stick
with slashing greenhouse gas emissions
we are recommending that the 2040 Target
should be a 90% cut in
emissions so why we're making this
recommendation now well at risk of
repeating myself because the case for
climate action is beyond doubt and
requires planning in the Here and Now
words that are unlikely to find a
sympathetic air among Farmers facing
debt and other price pressures and with
a new eu-wide treaty with South American
countries to import more Brazilian and
Argentinian beef many question the
environmental impact of such policies
and their financial effects Sonia GGO
alaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from aler
right